a
[Música]
ah
en medio de la pandemia del 19 el
servicio de delivery se incrementó en
perú en un 250 por ciento durante la
cuarentena y un 200% respecto al año
anterior según algunos expertos pero
quienes se dedican en esta actividad
revelan de que no de la prosperidad que
reciben las plataformas digitales
denuncian que trabajan un promedio de 13
horas diarias no cuentan con estabilidad
laboral ni beneficios sociales usan sus
propias motos gastan en combustible y
sus ingresos son menores al salario
mínimo los obtienen a través de
comisiones por pedidos los repartidores
señalan que las empresas no cumplen con
otorgar un bono en caso de salir
positivo al coronavirus y denuncian que
reciben instrucciones para evitar las
pruebas de descarte que las autoridades
realizan la asociación de consumidores y
usuarios le exigió al gobierno peruano
fiscalizar el servicio ante esto el
primer ministro walter marcos lanzó un
plan para supervisar el cumplimiento de
protocolos de bioseguridad y así
controlar los niveles de contagio del
coronavirus la estrategia involucrar a
2400 autoridades entre policías miembros
de las fuerzas armadas y funcionarios
públicos
[Música]
en medio de la pandemia creció de forma
exponencial el comercio online en
portugal sobre todo el área de servicios
de comida y take away que aumentó un 53
por ciento también aumentó
considerablemente el número de
repartidores en la calle según la
plataforma fijando entre marzo y mayo
del presente año más de 2.000 personas
se incorporaron este tipo de trabajos un
servicio prácticamente inexistente
portugal hace tres años were its por
ejemplo llegó al país en noviembre 2017
y alcanzaba 90 establecimientos hoy en
día más de 4 mil restaurantes forman
parte de esta plataforma y más de 1000
se incorporaron en medio de la pandemia
pero cuáles son las condiciones
laborales de estos repartidores no son
las más ideales no tienen seguro social
sin embargo aseguran si es un trabajo
lucrativo en medio de la crisis ha
aumentado la demanda y por ende el
ingreso aseguran que si antes hacían
diez carreras en un día ahora hacen
entre 20 y 30 y asegura además ganar más
del salario mínimo es un trabajo que
sobre todo realizan los inmigrantes del
país especialmente los brasileros sin
embargo les llama la atención que en los
últimos meses incluso portugueses se han
incorporado a este tipo de servicios
[Música]
en ecuador los repartidores las
distintas aplicaciones digitales han
sido los protagonistas silenciosos para
mantener los empleos durante la pandemia
pero a pesar que las ventas electrónicas
se incrementaron cinco veces más que los
ingresos obtenidos en comparación al año
2019 según la cámara ecuatoriana del
comercio electrónico también se
incrementaron las ventas en motocicletas
muchas personas cambiaron a este sector
económico y las ventas electrónicas
pasaron de 100 a 500 dólares por
promedio con eventos denominados como
los cyber day los repartidores protestan
que han realizado caravanas y reclamos
por mayores pagos y seguridad sanitaria
para realizar sus labores o sindicato de
repartidores aseguran que elaboran 10
horas diarias los 7 días de la semana
con condiciones que califican de
precarias piden que se restituya la
tarifa base de un dólar con 30 centavos
por kilometraje con el trabajo que
estuvieron realizando hasta el pasado
mes de noviembre los repartidores
reclaman que sus ingresos han disminuido
y no les alcanza para mantener sus
vehículos ni a sus familias pero la
crisis económica también motivó al
gobierno nacional a gravar impuestos el
valor agregado iva a unos 169 servicios
y 203 aplicaciones digitales
cualquier para recordar 5 millones de
dólares
[Música]